all right
as the rest of us slept Australia was
among the first to see in Christmas
from hymns to hitting the waves at manly
Beach the birth of Jesus is celebrated
around the world in a multitude of ways
here in Taipei a light show
meanwhile in Bethlehem the City built on
a story of faith
tending midnight mass was Palestinian
leader Mahmoud Abbas a reminder of the
historic conflict in the region you know
we as Christians are hopeful for a
bright future for this land for peace
and justice for all people for security
for Israel as well as self-determination
for the Palestinian but a modern
conflict dominated this year's Christmas
Day
no lights in Ukraine as blackouts
continue after Russian bombardment
but it won't stop the festivities
[Music]
Jingle Bell Rock Ukrainian style this
underground Opera concert comes as the
country marks 10 months since the
Russian invasion although even better
spirits can't hide the fact that
Christmas here is a reminder of what's
been lost
unfortunately this year all holidays
have a bitter taste for us and we can
feel the traditional spirits of
Christmas differently dinner at The
Family Table may not be so tasty and
warm there may be empty chairs around it
and our homes and streets may not be so
bright and Christmas bells may not sound
so loud and inspiring because of Air
Raid Sirens or even worse shots and
explosions
calling for an end to the war in his
Christmas speech the Archbishop of
Canterbury in Ukraine let Russia
withdraw
let there be a ceasefire as the whole
world Longs for
and at the Vatican Ukraine Central to
the Pope's sermon for the world's
Catholics
let our eyes be filled with the faces of
our Ukrainian brothers and sisters who
are living this Christmas in the dark
and cold far from their homes due to the
devastation and destruction caused by
months of War
christmas its Traditions may vary but at
its heart the same call
Global need for Goodwill subur Chowdhury
Sky News